I'm going to suggest to you today that we
start referring to Donald Trump's tariffs
as tax increases on everyday Americans because
that's what they actually are in practice.
And that's something I thought that Republicans
claim to be against.
And I've been talking about this since Donald
Trump's tariffs on China.
We're just an idea now.
There are a reality, as I told you in the
last segment, new tariffs have been announced
on Mexico.
Those start at 5% potentially escalating all
the way up to 25% according to Donald Trump.
If you believe that, uh, that is actually
what he is going to do.
Now, it's really important to understand,
and I feel like a broken record with this.
China doesn't pay the tariffs that Donald
Trump placed on them.
Mexico will not pay the tariffs that Donald
Trump is placing on that is in the process
of placing on them.
The tariffs on China and Mexico make their
stuff more expensive to import to the United
States.
So when you import it, you pay China or Mexico
the same amount for their stuff.
Plus you pay something to the United States
government.
In addition to that, a tariff, it is effectively,
it is effectively a tax.
Trump has said times his tariffs are forcing
China to pay however many billions of dollars.
That's just not how it works.
If China has a $100 product that the United
States buys and you put a 25% tariff on Chinese
goods, the American company or person who
buys the hundred dollar thing from China is
still paying China, just the a hundred bucks
and then in addition to that, they pay the
US government 25 bucks.
In the case of a hypothetical 25% tariff,
what this means is that the American company
or the American person paying the tariff on
the Chinese stuff ends up with $25 that they
could have spent at local businesses, could
have spent in other ways within the American
economy, but they don't have those 25 bucks
because they paid it to the government as
a tariff.
I thought that small government, low tax conservatives
were against that and they wanted Americans
to keep more of their own money in order to
do whatever they want in order to stimulate
local business.
This is bad for the United States.
This boycott this, I'm sorry.
This tariff program is crushing soybean exports,
which are down 97% from 2017 in the United
States.
Trump's tariffs are crushing whiskey exports
because of the retaliatory tariffs that are
put in place.
Whiskey exports down 32% in the fourth quarter
of 2018 compared to the fourth quarter of
2017 and unfortunately this is the most disgusting
part of it all.
Donald Trump genuinely doesn't seem to understand
the basics of how tariffs work, and it's not
actually super shocking that it's not being
corrected because Trump's administration has
no serious or credible economics people remaining.
There's this guy, Larry Kudlow, who Trump
seems to ignore any way and whose opinion
Trump has previously disavowed when it wasn't
in line with what Donald Trump wanted to believe.
Look at the tweets that Donald Trump posted
over the weekend quote in order not to pay
tariffs.
If they start rising, companies will leave
Mexico, which has taken 30% of our auto industry
and come back home to the United States.
Mexico must take back their country from the
drug lords and cartels.
The tariff is about stopping drugs as well
as illegals.
It I, I'm, I'm almost at a loss for words
because Mexican companies aren't going to
leave Mexico to avoid paying the tariffs because
they don't pay the tariffs.
It's the Americans paying the tariffs when
they buy or import Mexican stuff.
Donald Trump has weaponized his ignorance
on this issue and probably on some others.
Remember when he called his now indicted National
Security Advisor, Michael Flynn in the middle
of the night to ask him, Hey, Michael is a
strong dollar or a weak dollar, good for the
United States.
Remember when Trump campaigned endlessly on
how he was going to fix healthcare, which
he didn't, by the way, and then it was revealed
through something Trump said at one of his
speeches that he seemed confused between health
insurance and life insurance.
He confused the two.
I won't rehash the whole story.
We've done a couple of segments about it.
I know we already talked about the Mexican
tariffs, but the Mexico tariff idea is incredible
in how massively negative it's going to be
for everybody.
Tariffs on Mexican stuff will make things
more expensive for Americans, which is not
good for the economy, for the American economy.
It will potentially hurt the Mexican economy,
which will push more Mexicans to want to come
to the United States, whether it's legally
or illegally, which is what Donald Trump claims
to want to stop.
So number one, we've got to start calling
these tariffs taxes.
Maybe we call it an excise tax.
Um, uh, since, uh, excise taxes are taxes
on specific goods or services.
Like you pay excise tax on a car for example,
or on specific activities.
Sometimes excises are paid, I don't know,
that is based, will notice or care.
They probably see Trump putting tariffs on
Mexico.
Like the idea of, Oh, we're hurting brown
people and that's a good thing.
I don't know,
but we've got to change the language around
it.
It's getting really bad.
Make sure you follow us on Instagram at David.
[inaudible] quick break back after this,